>>Sal Khan: So when most people
think about what education is,
there's actually a
whole spectrum of stuff.
So if you imagine over here,
this is kind of the most-
the most rote form of education.
This is, you know, your
multiplication facts or dates
in history or vocabulary.
And then as you go in this
direction you get kind
of the more open-ended
and creative things.
So this is creativity --
creativity and open-endedness.
And what's happening right now
is there's definitely creativity
and open-endedness
happening in classrooms,
but I think almost every
educator I talk to says
that they wish they had more time
for doing that type of stuff.
So in a trad- right now our
traditional education system is
focused kind of on this
part of the spectrum.
So this is- this is
where it's focused now.
Now what's been interesting about
Khan Academy is we've been able to --
with a combination of -- obviously,
we've got videos, we've got software,
which are our exercises
and our dashboards.
We're gonna have our
community of students
who are able to help each other.
We think this virtual
component can start to address --
can start to address a lot of this.
And it goes into things
that are quite conceptual
and quite open-ended
and project-based.
We have computer science
and other things.
We have simulations.
A lot of the videos go into the
conceptual understanding of things,
but the value here, the value
of what Khan Academy we think can
be over time, is not to replace this,
by no means to replace this.
I have kids myself and I do
not want them to just learn
from a virtual school or spend
all their time in the classroom.
We think the opportunity is that
the physical classroom then moves
over here.
It becomes even more
open-ended and more creative.
And so our view of the summer
camp is to really experiment
with what we can do over here.
So this is what we're doing right
over here in our Discovery Lab.
And that's why you're gonna see at
this "camp" I guess we can call it --
you're gonna see a lot
more kinds of simulations.
And when I talk about- we're talking
about real world games: kids trading,
kids talking to each other.
We're gonna see a lot of
projects: students building robots,
students tearing down
electronic devices and figuring
out what all of the things do.
You're gonna see a lot more real
world, real-world mathematics,
so a lot of probability
and statistics,
and also kind of tactile mathematics.
We will see three-dimensional
geometry.
These kids are going to build
three-dimensional Sierpinskis,
tetrahedrons, and whatever else.
And so, really, this is all
about "What could the future
of physical classrooms look like?"
And this is a really important
point, because whenever people think
about virtual education, they always
think of it as an either/or: oh,
virtual education versus physical.
But we think virtual
education is going
to make physical education
more valuable and, in actuality,
it makes it even more valuable.
So, ironically, the kind
of, the school of the future,
"the physical," in our minds, are
going to become even more important.
And so what we're hoping to
do is we're gonna experiment
with all these things, see what
works, what doesn't work and then see
if we can scale it up to
the rest of the world.
We can share what has worked,
and so any teacher, any student,
any parent anywhere can do
some of these simulations,
projects and real-world games.